[Music]  my name is Alice ready kill me  this has been my whole life  we're here today to talk about our  destiny we're here to talk about the end  of the world  everything is led to this I can't run  anymore and 14 hours humanity will be no  more there's a way to end all this why  should I trust you I cannot do something  you wanna learn that revenge  umbrella developed cure and airborne  antivirus I have to get to the hive it's  our only chance now  oh my god there's an army of them in our  way what are we gonna do we're gonna  kill every last one of them  let's go  dama  I killed your Washington  yeah big mistake  all this could end I'm gonna stop  umbrella  whatever it takes  something stuck in us you sure this is  what I do  sometimes I feel like this has been my  whole life  ready  joy